Peter's birthday on Friday I think the
best gift we can give him is the power
of advertisement
you're saying we make an ad that has
nothing to do with
the draws it people Peter's gonna be so
excited when he sees the numbers that we
present him what if this works this
could actually work what if we
all right so clearly we have a little
bit of a problem in that uh it's Peter's
birthday on Friday and I totally forgot
that that was a thing I've known Peter
for a pretty long time now and the fact
that I forgot that is I mean it looks
bad for me he will not be happy anything
you ordered on Amazon is going to take
too long to get here you'll you'll smell
an Amazon gift he doesn't care if I
don't get him one we're not birthday
friends we're not like birthday friends
you're a birthday friends we're birthday
friends he remembers my birthday I
remember his we get each other stuff we
plan ahead he calls me every night I
want that
hey buddy happy birthday to you
[Music]
oh my God you guys are even three days
early
oh yeah we no we knew that we knew that
we wanted to like you know we wanted to
be the first we wanted to be the first
ones we did we got you a gift yeah but
um we kind of put our heads together and
went like well I mean I think the best
gift we can give him is uh the power of
advertisement we know that you have like
a VR game coming out right uh and it
looks really cool it looks awesome yeah
we've seen it on Instagram
what's that wait who else is there oh
Jordan yes Jordan Allen Jordan's here as
well yeah
yeah so so Jordan and I both uh were
here's where I come in I'll help you to
elevate my status with Peter as a
birthday friend because the best way to
get gifts is to give them first and we
thought what better gesture than to
offer to make him an incredible game ad
yes and we know how to make game ads
right
yeah I mean the game almost sells itself
so it's almost not even going to be that
difficult but I feel super lucky this is
awesome thank you guys
nope he sounds down that I feel really
good about this now he's legitimately
making a really awesome looking game
he's been working so hard on it I'm
really excited now we're not admin right
yes like the Mad Men are we don't drink
at work well you don't the thing is we
can do market research you know we can
study the trends I'm into it man well
what's his game about it's first person
VR shooter yes vibey has like a little
bit of an old school like 90s video
games retro aesthetic okay what what
works teaser okay so we have like
lots of Bones yeah yeah bones oh this is
cool okay so I mean there there's just
like a lot of really hype looking shots
cool action moments and we can
definitely do some of that I don't know
you know what Jordan I think I have an
idea
wait because I've seen okay hold on a
second I've seen some of these you've
seen kinds of ads yeah so she farts
herself into a zombie State yes which I
get like that that makes sense but how
does her fart turn her into this offer I
think it would turn him look we don't
have to look into this too much because
it's not they don't even care is there a
is there an overarching plot it's kind
of like the mobile game ad and the
mobile game itself are completely
separate from each other they don't
exist in the same universe yeah but
they're so uh ridiculous and compelling
that I think it gets people to click on
last year alone mobile games generated
92.2 billion dollars that's in one year
PC and console games combined are
basically the same amount of Revenue in
one year as the mobile game sector which
is insane to think about because they're
dinky little games you're saying we make
an ad that has nothing to do with the
game at all it just draws people in and
then when they download it just like
those ads I'm guessing the game's
nothing like it but at least it's a good
game I actually love that so much hold
on show me stuff show me like check this
one out here okay so she has stinky
hairy legs they're rubbing her legs and
they're they're cheering her yeah so
she's got stinky feet and hairy legs
life is so unfair you need to help her
out and this is all a game about like uh
dressing up it's like a dress-up game
who is she why do we trade you know I'm
fed up with this world because you can't
have children man she's Barren and now
she's homeless but it's about a card
game
and that's the thing like it's an
emotional response you get when you
watch these especially like the first
five seconds of it is so important he
leaves his friend to die and then
creates a bunker yes step one build a
home entertainment system while your
friend dies this is another one of these
zombie ones head butt head butt into the
butt double slot because they're both
pissed now we need your help so he kills
her so he kills us this one is
interesting wow okay so this is also a
card game but this is this is gameplay
you got to get this these cards to melt
the ice I'm on the toilet I'm
overwhelmed so that you can plunge it so
that she can finally make her stinky poo
poos wait so can I just make sense of
this no try you can't it and now she's
dead how did you fail and this is for
Home Design This is a game that's not
even about cards
it's a it's Home Design they generally
don't care what do you see right away
with this zombie home by the top humble
at the top yeah hold on what's he saying
amazing Graphics great storyline it's
the perfect balance of excitement
Adventure strategy critical thinking
then the taunt try it and prove me wrong
this guy doesn't even look like he's
actually playing the game he's got a
gamer chair he he's just saying like
vague nonsense that could relate to any
game to be honest I love game and I
don't like it when game is not what game
says this game is the game you can prove
me wrong true now this one is called
Hollywood Story oh and for a hurry make
me the hottest woman you're putting fish
in her hair yes and all that he's with a
pregnant woman oh well they're both
pregnant though there's another common
theme in these ads is that they're
they're bearing children for summer all
the time clearly it's effective because
so many different types of games are
using themselves I mean there's
something relatable to it yeah it's like
we've all been in the womb We All Get It
win the king's heart and amass tons of
riches oh she's pregnant yep you're
right console can't get pregnant Let It
Be brainstorm
they do some stuff in them uh with a
servant so her by brainstorm she she
gets pregnant sex in a bush this in the
Middle Ages they have pregnancy tests
she gets pregnant but wait a second
he realizes the baby wasn't hers these
are nuts why should the baby say damn
but that's what gives it away you will
go insane if you overthink these things
what turning is that's what they want
you to do Jordan if you can I mean these
guys are making billions if you can make
billions using this strategy with a
crappy game on the back end then it only
makes sense that if we use those same
strategies with a good game Peter's game
then we would make two three four times
the amount we almost need to make this
like the mega ad of ads where every
single thing that pulls your attention
needs to be in this let's just literally
put down the biggest tropes that we
sides pregnancy the memory once lived in
each of all of us it's the it's the
tether uh stinky poo-poos it needs to be
stinky it needs to be muddy it needs to
be dirty let's go from womb to tomb and
throw down zombies zombies zombies we
gotta have like some kind of undead
element yes right I think broader
Strokes here we need like a relationship
drama aspect oh interesting okay so
relationship drama rage rage bait that's
a great way to put it rage bait rage
bait slash math math math math yes oh oh
uh false influencer testimonial telling
you this is the game the other games are
in the game Sorry hold on kill some of
your brain cells real quick yes
if we could also do as like a cherry on
top a cameo from someone who Peter looks
up to and respects that's like a an
extra freaking gift
yeah I think this is a good list
honestly we really just need to tether
them together with like a good story I
think we can do that I think we can
keeping in mind we got beats we got all
the Beats we figured out what we're
doing here last night into the wee hours
we came up with Concept we're very proud
of yes we're gonna do two ads here we're
gonna do a serious one that we're really
pushing on to just showcase his gameplay
because he has some really sweet
gameplay footage and we want to just
kind of make a cool trailer Montage
cutter but as the numbers indicate
there's no billionaires in that industry
they probably are but we know there are
billionaires in this industry and so it
makes sense to us we're not going to
reference it at all we are going to go
for whatever we'll draw the most
attention and we think we have that here
it is equal parts sexy exciting
frustrating and beautiful you know Nick
because moments like this where you have
the whole thing laid out in a storyboard
that you realize this is really stupid
but I can't wait
we we've never tested this stuff
ourselves we don't know how this is
actually going to perform so I'm really
interested to see like how an actual
serious version of this ad is going to
compare against something that is just
so tasteless
[Applause]
yeah yeah
I'm curious we'll see what happens we
don't have time to animate all this
stuff there's a lot of like little
details to the animation so we need to
get Jordan in a mocap suit and we need
to do motion capture that kind of feels
like it's jankly animated we want it to
feel like an animator is paid not nearly
enough to make these animations embrace
the mud you're covered in mud pregnant
with a little Gremlin man look we got
our top men on the job and I don't know
what they're doing but you know I trust
them so that's all I can say he barely
knows anything about the time what is
this it says we need to do a take called
birth
our work's cut out for us here let's hit
the board right what do we got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve and then when we enter the
2D space I'm going to need one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen separate 3D animations on Alpha
to give to him to put into his 2D space
so in total
it's a lot
remember earlier when you're talking
about getting a cameo for Peter from a
celebrity no that didn't really make it
into the advertisements but we still
wanted to do it anyway because we
thought it would be funny we got Peter a
cameo a real Cameo from some of his
favorite artists the island boys it's
hilarious that's all on our Vlog right
now so if you want to watch that whole
Cameo Saga and Peter's reactions you can
head on over to Corridor digital.com and
check it out for yourself so we are a
couple days further down the pipeline
here and things are getting pretty crazy
we have a ton of custom motion capture
data and we're talking about 13
different characters all these models I
found on sketchfab and had to rig from
the ground up that's skeleton that's
facial animation and everything in
between but thankfully in Houdini
everything is very procedural so once I
set up one rig I can then just customize
it and tweak it to fit for another rig
and that's the only thing that's made
this possible so our main character
stinky girl she's a complex one she's
covered in mud at certain points that
mud needs to erode away she needs to
blend between a ton of different actions
that we captured she needs some parts of
her to grow rapidly let's take a little
tour of our stinky girl hair the first
thing we have is a motion capture data
obviously very important and as you can
see here we've got the actual action
itself right we've got Boom the initial
spanking and then the turnaround in
reaction and we did all of these actions
separately so that on the back end I had
more flexibility as to when and where to
transition between these animations
Houdini has some really awesome options
where we can do that very very easily
this is a blend of three separate
actions the initial spanking here it
Blends from here into the jump and then
the celebration but we also have the
face to think about so I built what's
called a blend shape rig I post her face
in different instances I shut mouth open
smiling frowning and everything in
between and then I simplified it down to
a slider control and if I want her
eyebrows to go up in shock I raise the
slider if I want it down I lower the
slider terrified of the Smile by the way
I'm really proud of that one the final
few features that really make this
character
iconic what if I told you there was a
way to make an expandable and
contractible booty belly combo inside of
a character for Wicked quick animation
creative notes come down they're going
hey she's not pregnant she's supposed to
be extra pregnant right nice job because
our girls getting preggers
look at that a dynamic pregnancy system
this is real time baby the cheeks they
just don't stop I mean all these things
right we get like let's say we want both
Dynamic but Dynamic belly you have it's
just an incredible tool here this is
just the beginning again it's the idea
of keeping it all procedural is so that
at the drop of a hat we can change
animations right and this exists across
13 different characters but thanks to
the power of proceduralism inside of
Houdini it's all very possible so while
Jordan over there is hard at work making
our 3D cut scene I am taking a lot of
assets and animations that Jordan made
for me and bringing them into the 2D
space very basically we just have a set
of animations and a background that
we've generated sort of an environment
which creates our level of this game so
it's just very basically animating with
our characters here who are butt run
this is just like a walk cycle using the
cheeks we got some stuff like butt turn
very important Gremlin dance also
incredibly important we need a good
Gremlin dance you know we got to get the
tick tock kids in on this we got parents
crying they lost him in a pipe right
down a drain they need to save this boy
somehow so there's always like math
involved in the gameplay of these mobile
game ads uh addition and subtraction
just really basic math like oh plus
three this is a good thing I pulled this
pipe I get good star I pull minus five
negative oh that's bad don't pull that
one but guess what these guys
they pull it anyway
they're pulling it anyway we're trying
to draw frustration from the audience
like they're getting it wrong in this
gameplay and and as a player you can do
better this is Rage bait if they're
messing up well I just download the app
I download the app for myself and then I
play game I make Victory get three stars
on top of that though I feel like we
needed to add a human element you know
an influencer someone uh someone with
Charisma and more specifically a
punchable face because
just look at that oh this guy you want
to slap him we just wanted to like add
to the credibility by saying like he's
playing the game telling you that it's
real that's important one more thing we
have to do as well is we need to record
some ADR some Foley a lot of
requires eager beavers on that one the
whole point of this is to show Peter
that we're the admin for him right get
him a birthday gift and also get
ourselves a little bit of a lucrative
paycheck on the back end so we're
pulling real analytics from Instagrams
at two ads this is an A B test right so
the a trailer is our cinematic uh VR
experience right this actually shows
Peter's game hard shot and on the B side
and the Beast we've got our Beauty our
little baby in waiting and I hope I hope
Peter appreciates it you know we've
poured our Blood Sweat and brain cells
into this and those brain cells we're
not getting them back no we are Dumber
for having done this so this is the
final push we have to get these ads
running by this evening
um so that means one thing we're gonna
need more markers that's right
we are perspiring a little bit we're
nervous is Peter here he's here Peter's
here oh we don't know where he is but
he's like he's in the building a little
nervous yeah yeah oh my God right oh
we poured ourselves into this for you
and we're very very excited for your
response what an amazing birthday gift
you guys are you guys are the best yeah
I feel so special you're the best part
you're the best you're my best friend
okay
first and foremost we have a briefcase
over here that we brought oh
there we go oh don't really should have
cleaned that up this is this is a car is
this a card what is the is this it is
this a contract this is a birthday
contract yeah I feel like I should read
this but I don't know if we have time to
this is where the trust comes in okay
there's nothing based on my moral
compass that I would flag I really feel
like I should have read that you're good
I've never heard of a legally binding
birthday card well I've never heard of
such an awesome birthday gift before so
you guys got a hour for it we do yes oh
my God the hard shot ad campaign happy
birthday Peter thanks guys mission
statement sell heart shot game using
marketing strategy and synergistic
developmental increase bottom line
values yep numbers and figures and
percentages that will make you rich
value like moving on yeah yeah okay
implementation of the ad our goal was
simple we want to showcase the game as
it is we want to allow people a window
into what they might expect when they
Place head game
foreign
[Music]
damn
guys that was amazing that's what we did
that's gonna sell some copies great job
honestly no no no yeah sit down
sit down for just a second okay we also
created another ad yeah and that other
AD is our strategy for your marketing
campaign it's more of a creative Choice
yeah you know we've already run it
just to be aware that people have seen
it already it's been running for two
days let's actually show you the ad this
is the part we're really excited for
Peter yes as well I I cannot wait to see
this one
guys
is she pregnant
oh
wow
[Music]
don't you hate it when the game's not
the game this is the game
[Music]
this is on the Instagram
guys
[Music]
advertising you would think so yes this
is false advertising but the thing is
there's a loophole oh and it's a
beautiful loophole beautiful
we've already run the ad you are legally
now obligated
to include some of these elements what
in your game in your game it's it's
already done yep if you do not there
could be lawsuit all kinds of things
could happen what did I just sign that
was letting the courts know that we are
not responsible yeah we're not obligated
to for anything that might may or may
not happen but we thought that this
would be a great way to get the word out
I trusted you and this is not at all
what the game is about Peter Peter the
numbers don't lie ah yeah is it doing
well it's all about the numbers let's
talk numbers yes the data over the last
two days we ran both of these ads on
your actual Instagram account uh as an A
B test so we gather data from both ads
our mobile game ad has 500 more views
than the more traditional cinematic
version turns out you can lie to your
audience as long as you put some little
bit of what's in the game ad it becomes
an Easter egg for people who love you
and who want to see that game right and
we slip right on through that loophole
and become billionaires together
together also in the contract by the way
also in the contract I love this I love
I love the way you guys are thinking
this is brilliant I love the
questionable morality yes yeah it's
because that's how you make money I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it
oh oh
um
[Applause]
that's a happy camper that is and I'm
gonna be real with you since we're
putting all our cards on the table okay
I got into this initially for selfish
reasons okay I see the bond you two have
I see this birthday friendship
and I wanted that for myself with you
and I thought the best way would be to
get you an epic gift that you know
changes your life and then you would be
somewhat emotionally obligated to
celebrate my birthday moving forward and
I have to say the joy
that I'm seeing yes thank you
the joy that I'm seeing on your face
if you want to pursue a friendship with
me if you want to um form a birthday
friendship if we if you want to share in
that with me that is organic and that's
available to you but the debt is paid my
friend this this is enough for a
thousand birthdays not only did I I know
this was your intention when you called
me three days before my birthday you
knew we were already birthday friends my
friend
and now
we're best friends
oh
well like best best or are you talking
about like just best best best but we
were best best best right I'm one more
best above just he'll stop
this is really great it's my birthday
you know well when it is you'll be
getting
okay but like could I where are you guys
going
I guess all along
it was my heart that got shot
okay so Peter tell us seriously how can
people support your game heartshop all
right so while we have an Instagram at
heartshot game we're posting little
Clips there and updates and we're also
on my YouTube channel Peter France I'm
posting devlogs you know documenting the
process of making the game and updates
and things like that I'll be dropping
the trailer there soon so be sure to go
over and subscribe to my YouTube channel
and follow heartshot game on Instagram
and uh you can go check it out so thanks
for uh supporting the game and thank you
guys for making such beautiful
advertisements I think I think it's
going to go a long way with the success
of the game our pleasure brother our
pleasure thank you thank you thank you
yeah oh boy we lost him a lot of
followers so you should definitely you
got to make it up seriously someone's
got to make this help yeah